[Aplausos]
[Música]
a estas alturas creo que todos
absolutamente todos estáis
familiarizados con noticias como esta
aunque solo sea porque hemos hablado de
ello hace muy poquito tiempo aquí en
visualpolitik la Unión Europea Pide a
los países recortar la demanda de gas un
15% hasta la primavera La cruel e
injustificada invasión rusa de Ucrania y
las consiguientes sanciones
internacionales han puesto los países de
la Unión Europea justo en la Diana de
Vladimir Putin Y eso es algo que en
cierta forma resulta aterrador no
olvidéis que en países como la República
Checa Austria Alemania o Eslovaquia no
es extraño Que las temperaturas alcancen
los 15 grados bajo cero Así que pasar un
invierno sin calefacción es casi un reto
imposible de cumplir el problema tal y
como podéis ver en este mapa Es que
muchos países europeos se han vuelto
terriblemente dependientes del gas Ruso
y de todos ellos un caso llama
especialmente la atención por su enorme
consumo y por lo importante que resulta
su economía para toda la Unión Europea
empezando porque es con diferencia del
mayor contribuyente del club comunitario
Sí por supuesto estoy hablando de
Alemania
durante la primera mitad del 2022 y a
pesar de la Guerra de Ucrania la
dependencia alemana del gas ruso se
situó en torno al 40%. Esto hace que un
posible corte de gas por parte de Moscú
se perciba como toda una pesadilla tanto
en lo económico como en lo social un
corte del gas podría suponer que muchas
fábricas tuvieran que cerrar y que las
calefacciones dejaran de funcionar
mientras en invierno conduce las
temperaturas a varios grados bajo cero
para colmo las reservas de gas alemanas
se encuentran muy tensionadas y en el
momento de preparar Este vídeo se estima
que como mucho podría satisfacer la
demanda durante unos dos meses y medio
algo claramente insuficiente para
resistir todo el invierno 24 de junio de
2022 el regulador energético de Alemania
dice que el país puede soportar dos
meses y medio sin gas Ruso y que habrá
un otoño y un invierno difícil por
delante de hecho otras el corte del
Norte por mantenimiento durante 10 días
Alemania se vio obligada a tirar en
pleno verano de sus reservas para el
invierno lo que tal y como os podéis
imaginar Pues no ha contribuido
precisamente a que el país se prepare
para la llegada del frío el corte de gas
de Rusia está obligando al mayor
comprador de Europa de su suministro a
reducir las reservas de emergencia de
invierno la empresa ha tenido que
apoyarse en su suministros de emergencia
de invierno para cumplir con las
obligaciones contractuales con sus
clientes Ahora bien todo esto de la
enorme dependencia que Alemania tiene
con el gas ruso es algo que todos
sabemos hasta aquí nada nuevo La
pregunta es hasta dónde llega realmente
la adicción alemana al gas ruso como
demonio se llegó a esta situación porque
Alemania se expuso tanto a los
suministros de un país como Rusia es que
nadie vio el gigantesco riesgo político
que esto conllevaba pues queridos amigos
amigas Lo cierto es que la cosa viene de
lejos y no no existe un único
responsable ni siquiera el propio
excanciller yerves brother que terminó
siendo colocado por Putin como Ejecutivo
en varias empresas rusas cobrando una
millonada y que por supuesto ahora se ha
convertido en radiactivo nadie quiere
tener con él pero un momento porque en
este vídeo no solo Vamos a ver quiénes
son los culpables de esta enorme
debilidad de Alemania sino que también
vamos a intentar entender cuál es
exactamente la situación en la que se
encuentra hoy el país germano y lo que
esto puede conllevar así pues hay unas
cuantas preguntas que tenemos que
resolver cómo diantres los alemanes No
tuvieron en cuenta la seguridad del
suministro y el riesgo político a la
hora de diseñar su sistema energético
Quién o quiénes son Los Auténticos
responsables de todo este gigantesco
desanisado y lo que puede resultar aún
mucho pero que mucho más importante de
cara al futuro Qué puede ocurrir si
finalmente se interrumpe el suministro
de gas ruso a la mayor Potencia de
Europa Pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
mi amigo ruso
las relaciones entre los alemanes y los
rusos sobre todo lo que respecta la
cuestión energética no son precisamente
algo nuevo para que os hagáis una idea
el día 1 de febrero de 1970 altos cargos
políticos y responsables del sector
gasístico de Alemania y de la por aquel
entonces Unión soviética firmaron la
construcción del primer gasoducto entre
los yacimientos de Siberia y los
consumidores de la República Federal
alemana Sí sí lo habéis escuchado bien
ni siquiera el telón de acero la
impermeable y gélida Barrera que dominó
la Guerra Fría evitó que el gas ruso
comenzara a fluir desde los campos de
extracción soviéticos hasta occidente
y no solo se trata de que el gas
comenzara a fluir entre países
antagónicos sino que ni siquiera las
fuertes tensiones de la Guerra Fría
lograron poner en peligro el suministro
de esta forma poco a poco con el paso de
las décadas esta seguridad permite
ladrillo ladrillo desarrollar fuertes
lazos de confianza y amistad comercial
entre alemanes y los rusos unos lazos
que han llegado hasta ahora y que
tuvieron su Punto de partida con la
llamada ost politic un proceso de
normalización de las relaciones entre
Alemania occidental y el bloque del este
impulsado por el ex canciller Billy
brandt
[Música]
ahora bien no lo chupemos el dedo si
estos lazos perduraron en el tiempo es
porque durante prácticamente 50 largos
años estas relaciones rusos germanas
conllevaron muchos beneficios para las
dos partes sin ir más lejos Alemania
estuvo durante décadas aprovechándose de
un suministro abundante y muy barato de
gas con el que por ejemplo alimentó su
avanzaba industria pesada una industria
que gracias a este suministro se colocó
en una posición muy competitiva tanto a
nivel europeo como a nivel mundial y de
hecho eso es precisamente lo que explica
que el consumo Alemán de gas ruso no
dejará de crecer hasta el año 2021
a cambio Rusia no solo recibió una
inmensa cantidad de dólares sino que
Alemania también trató a este país como
un socio prioritario y le vendió todo
tipo de bienes industriales y tecnología
avanzada Así que era Por así decirlo
unwing muy claro pero volvamos a la
pregunta que hacíamos antes Por qué
Alemania occidental tomó la decisión de
echarse en brazos de la unión soviética
y el bloque del este para resolver sus
necesidades energéticas Pues bien para
responder a esta pregunta tenemos que
ponernos en situación en aquella época
los políticos alemanes estaban
convencidos y la historia demuestra que
no estaban tan equivocados que promover
el comercio con el bloque del Este era
la mejor forma de mejorar la estabilidad
política en toda Europa Cuanto más
comercio mejor que mejor y a ver desde
luego nos seremos nosotros quienes
intenten refutar esa idea para nada El
problema es que el comercio de energía
no es como comprar o vender coches
lavavajillas o zapatillas la energía
amigos es la base del sistema productivo
y económico y por eso garantizar el
suministro de energía en cualquier
circunstancia e incluso Aunque pueda
conllevar mayores costes resulta algo
fundamental sin embargo un momento
porque la idea de que algo pudiera
detener el suministro ni siquiera se
pasó por la cabeza de los políticos
alemanes hasta hace prácticamente cuatro
días
una interrupción de largo plazo del
suministro energético iría en contra de
los propios intereses de la unión
soviética informe de ministerios
alemanes finales de la década de 1980
los que comercen entre sí no se disparan
unos a otros helmed Smith es canciller
de Alemania occidental a Jimmy Carter
hablar de dependencia económica de Moscú
por parte de la República Federal en un
grado lo suficientemente grande como
para afectar a la política exterior
indica ignorancia o malicia helmut Smith
1980 y de esta forma hasta el año 2021
Alemania desarrolló una dependencia
salvaje hacia Rusia para ese año Ni más
ni menos que el 55% de todo su consumo
de gas procedía de las tierras de Pedro
el grande la percepción era que Cuanto
más gas ruso barato entrará en Alemania
Porque mejor
[Música]
así que por ejemplo cuando la producción
de gas alemana comenzó a menguar por el
agotamiento de los yacimientos y por las
presiones de los grupos ecologistas
sabéis lo que hicieron los alemanes tres
dos uno Exacto pedirle más gas a los
rusos
[Música]
ni siquiera tras la invasión y la
posterior anexión de criminal los
políticos alemanes tomaron medidas
serias para diversificar sus fuentes de
energía bueno es que de hecho hicieron
todo lo contrario fijaos 30 de mayo de
2011 Alemania cerrará todos los
reactores nucleares la medida está
motivada por las protestas masivas
contra la energía nuclear tras el
desastre nuclear de Japón pero claro a
quién le importaba mientras los
políticos alemanes pudieran vender
éxitos económicos y energía barata
porque preocuparse por Rusia para aquí
perder el tiempo pensando en cosas como
la seguridad energética y demás Aún si
podían hacer negocio este fue por
ejemplo el caso del scanciller de
Alemania general Quien dirigió el timón
de Alemania entre los años 1998 y 2005
no solo se jacta ha de ser colega de
Vladimir Putin y visitarlo
frecuentemente sino que también trabajo
para proyectos vinculados con el
gobierno ruso que el mismo había
promovido como canciller este fue el
caso por ejemplo del nord Stream una
empresa controlada por Rusia que fue la
encargada de construir el primer
gasoducto submarino que conecta
directamente a Rusia con Alemania
el propio Putin esto es Rueda era
convertirse en el presidente del comité
de accionistas así que de esta forma a
cambio de un generoso salario es brother
se encargó de promover las bondades del
gas ruso por toda Alemania y no fue su
única dedicación por ejemplo desde el
año 2017 es suéter también formó parte
de la junta directiva de la petrolera
rusa rosnev la recompensa por ese sillón
otros 600 mil dólares anuales que
aprovechó de la reputación influencia de
la cancillería y se ofreció como agente
de los intereses rusos para enriquecerse
norberton parlamentario conservador y
exministro Y por supuesto No fue un caso
aislado muchos políticos alemanes
directa o indirectamente participaron de
este enorme negocio Hasta que el globo
pum estalló su excusa era que Rusia
nunca cortaría el suministro de gas
porque no le interesaría asumir una
pérdida económica tan grande el problema
es que hoy sabemos que no todo el mundo
se comporta de una forma tan eficiente
como los rígidos políticos alemanes si
una vez más algo nos ha enseñado
Vladimir Putin es que en ocasiones la
opción más racional no es la opción
escogida bueno es que en otra
circunstancias nunca hubiera tenido
lugar la invasión de Ucrania Así que
teniendo esto presente La pregunta es
hasta dónde llega exactamente el
problema de Alemania Pues bien veámoslo
el juego que empieza perdido
pese a todos los esfuerzos que se han
realizado para reducirla la dependencia
alemana de las ruso sigue siendo de
entorno al 40% de todo su consumo de gas
y si eso ya es preocupante hay números
que son incluso peores la situación Se
volverá aún Peor si las importaciones o
los suministros de gas y petróleo rusos
se detienen una recesión significativa
en Alemania sería entonces virtualmente
Inevitable Christian siving ceo de
deutsche Bank y amigos tenés presente
una cosa estas palabras podrían quedarse
cortas me explico esto que veis en
pantalla es la forma en la que se
reparte el consumo de gas en Alemania
como veis el mayor consumidor de gas es
la industria en particular la industria
pesada que es terriblemente intensiva en
energía en total se traga casi el 40%
del consumo total luego están los
hogares que son responsables de algo más
del 30% del consumo de gas y con el cual
se abastecen de calefacción agua
caliente y energía para cocinar
principalmente y luego entre el 9 y el
15% de todo el gas consumido se destina
a la producción eléctrica Así que según
las estimaciones de diversas
instituciones si Rusia completamente el
suministro de gas además de pasar frío
los alemanes se enfrentarían una
importante recesión económica y como los
alemanes sobre todo los políticos
alemanes le tienen auténtico pavor a las
crisis ahora podéis entender Por qué han
forzado la comisión europea a imponer un
plan para reducir el consumo de gas en
toda Europa Claro que un momento porque
no todo es culpa de Rusia la propia
Alemania ha sido un cómplice necesario
para llegar a esta situación y no no
solo hablamos del dinero ruso
[Música]
con la llamada transición energética
Alemania ha cerrado Durante los últimos
años 14 de sus 17 reactores nucleares en
principio con la idea de sustituirlos
por energías limpias el problema amigos
es que las energías renovables más
habituales esto es la energía eólica y
la energía solar no tienen como todos
sabéis una producción regular Así que
necesitan una tercera fuente de energía
que actúe como respaldo y la política
alemanada ha hecho que esas centrales
sean precisamente las verás Pero eso ni
siquiera es todo Alemania también tiene
mucho más difícil sustituir el gas ruso
que otro de los países europeos Por qué
Pues porque no tienen infraestructuras
alternativas me explico como el gas ruso
llegaba a raudales por los gasoductos
Alemania nunca apostó por construir
regasificadoras con la que poder
importar gas natural licuado el gnl para
los que no lo sepáis es la forma en la
que el gas se transporta en estado
líquido a bordo de enormes metaneros con
lo cual al llegar a Puerto se necesita
de unidades de regasificación para
devolverlo de forma segura a su estado
gaseoso y así pues poder utilizarlo es
decir No solo hablamos de que los
alemanes no buscaran fuentes
alternativas y no se preocuparan de su
enorme tendencia del gas ruso es que ni
siquiera construyeron una
infraestructura alternativa por si las
moscas tal y como se hicieron otros
países por ejemplo hace aproximadamente
una década un país tan pequeñito como
lituania invirtió en una terminal
flotante para almacenar y regasificar el
gas natural adecuado se llama
Independencia y se encuentra anclada en
el puerto de caida Pues bien esta planta
le ha permitido a lituania convertirse
en el primer país europeo en dejar de
comprarle por completo gas a Rusia sea
como sea si algo está claro es que
Alemania tiene por delante un escenario
bastante complicado Y eso eso explica
que de cara al invierno se hayan puesto
manos a la obra para reducir el consumo
de gas por ejemplo están reactivando sus
viejas centrales eléctricas de Carbón y
amigos justo aquí aparece también la
cuestión nuclear
[Música]
tras el accidente de fukushima Merkel
decidió Cerrar todas las plantas
nucleares de Alemania una postura que
con el paso del tiempo se ha convertido
en toda una política de estado que sin
embargo ahora se está gritando y el
debate vuelve a estar sobre la mesa si
reactivamos las Tres plantas que fueron
apagadas el pasado diciembre podrían
junto a las 3 que aún operan reemplazar
todo el carbón que importamos de Rusia o
el 30% del gas ruso Marc bernhard
miembro del parlamento alemán por afd
aquí la reticencias para hacerlo no son
técnicas sino fundamentalmente políticas
y en estos momentos proceden sobre todo
de una parte muy concreta de la
coalición de gobierno sería un suicidio
para los verdes decir que estábamos
equivocados sobre la energía nuclear Así
que se ven obligados a continuar con el
viejo plan de batalla Thomas o'donnell
analista de energía y físico nuclear
basado en Alemania pero pese a todo No
Hay muchas más alternativas Así que como
mínimo es casi seguro que el cierre
programado de los tres reactores que
quedan operativos que estaba para
finales del 2022 se retrasará de forma
indefinida
soles abre la puerta a extender la
energía nuclear en Alemania
3 de agosto de 2022 soles dice que puede
tener sentido mantener funcionando las
centrales nucleares de Alemania bueno
así están las cosas por el corazón de la
vieja Europa pero llegados hasta aquí
turno para ti crees que Rusia le
terminará cortando todo el suministro de
gas Alemania se verá obligada a la vieja
Europa a tener que racionar el gas y lo
que resultaba mucho pero que mucho más
importante a largo plazo habrán
aprendido de una vez por todas los
alemanes lo importante que resulta
garantizar la seguridad energética
déjanos tu opinión por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y ya sabéis si este vídeo se
ha resultado interesante no olvidéis
darle A Like suscribiros si aún no lo
habéis hecho además si os gusta nuestro
trabajo y queréis echarnos una mano para
que podamos seguir creciendo y mejorando
podéis hacerlo formando parte de nuestra
comunidad en patreon además recibiréis
un montón de beneficios os dejo el
enlace en la descripción pero dicho esto
una vez más Muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]